faudrait à la fois dire deux mots sur
les racines et sur la diversité
un peuple sans histoire c'est un peuple
sans avenir
un peuple qui ne connaît pas ses racines
c'est un peuple aveugle sur la suite
et franchement quand le président
sarkozy dit qu'il faut respecter
il faut reconnaître les racines judéo
chrétiennes de la france ça n'est en
rien ni de la ségrégation ni du
sectarisme
c'est simplement s'appuyer sur ce qui a
fait l'histoire de ce pays
les coutumes les héros et grande voix de
ce pays pour se projeter
on ne se projette pas quand on n'a pas
de racines on ne se projette pas quand
on n'a pas la conscience de ce qu'est
notre histoire nationale
notre histoire nationale n'a pas
toujours été formidable mais au moins il
faut en avoir conscience
au moins il faut la connaître au moins
il faut la respecter
au moins il faut l'apprécier et je crois
qu'effectivement le respect des racines
c'est la meilleure moyenne la meilleure
manière d'aller vers l'avenir et en même
temps je veux répondre à notre ami des
hauts-de-seine sur la diversité
oui la diversité c'est important est
ailleurs dans les hauts-de-seine
quand je regarde les municipales de 2014
dans nos majorités municipales
républicaine nous avons extrêmement
élargit le spectre de la représentation
qu'on ne pas comme ou 10 c'est toujours
les mêmes
certaines y sont pas je verrai
d'ailleurs avec le nouveau président la
fédération philippe juvin nous allons
désigner un délégué départemental à
diversité pas pour faire des cases pas
pour faire des casses et pour que tout
le monde trouve sa place dans la vie de
nos fédérations
la diversité c'est aussi
le respect des racines et les racines
c'est aussi le fait que la diversité
c'est du plus c'est de la
sensibilisation
c'est de l'augmentation de notre nation
mais la nation c'est d'abord les racines